men tend to be The Gatekeepers and the  decision makers as to whether something  goes to a relationship or a marriage so  if you're not behaving so what you'll do  you're setting the criteria and say your  guy has to explain this to a certain way  but as far as relationships and marriage  is concerned you're not in a position to  lay out that criteria it's the guide  that's laying out the criteria and  saying listen  I expect my girlfriend if she trusts me  and she wants to be with me to listen to  what I'm saying it doesn't mean she  doesn't have a voice but ultimately if I  have something to say I can't I haven't  got time to be drawing her a diagram and  giving all these long-winded  explanations if she's not willing to  listen to me she hasn't really selected  me as her man